this is from
comptroller.nyc.gov this is not a news
article it's an official government
Source saying New York City banking
commission votes to approve 26
depository banks for two years limits
new deposits at Capital One and Key Bank
now why is it that they're restricting
deposits at Capital One Bank let me tell
you they say
following the first ever public hearing
held by the New York City banking
commission today all three members voted
to limit deposits at Capital One in Key
Bank after the banks failed to submit
required plans demonstrating their
efforts to root out discrimination it's
honestly that's a fair response I think
that's what had to happen I yeah I'm
actually on the left on this one I
actually no but I really am I I really
am they're gonna gut the major Banks
because they they
no that's not what I just think yeah
[Applause]
I think I don't know how racism is going
to end if they don't do this if if if
this is the if they're they're going to
consume each other and and the big you
know for it that's a good idea when when
the Federal Reserve announced they were
getting woke I was like oh no wait don't
do that yeah don't self-implode right
exactly no no but in all seriousness
yeah yeah this is this is this is scary
stuff look I just don't trust a bank
that doesn't wave rainbow flags and say
we are openly anti-racist hashtag uh BLM
it's not enough to be not racist you
have to be on board with our leftist
programs yeah we label anti-racism like
I just don't know how you could trust a
bank that isn't doing that how would
they demonstrated confidence if we're
talking about social justice maybe they
could give out copies of anti-racist
baby to all new customers I see now that
I think I'd be I if they're not to be to
be honest if they're not giving
genderqueer out to every customer I just
don't know how they could be a reliable
Bank anti-racist baby is a better book
to give do you think so yeah as he
racist baby is funnier to say so the
question the press release is saying
that uh they heard testimony from Muslim
New Yorkers who've experienced
discrimination process of open air
closing counts and then also climate
Advocates condemned the banks uh that
have continued to lend billions of
dollars to the fossil fuel expansion
okay what is the bank supposed to say
like well you're a fossil
no this is having made Net Zero
commission commitments this is a 12-year
plan by Occupy Wall Street to finally
get their revenge and it's working also
I want to mention it out so so these
bank loans are all predatory and you
have to pay a high interest rate and
we're like sad that they're not doing
that to the big oil companies okay so we
need to have a serious conversation with
our culture and we need to really talk
about how far this country has come in
terms of discrimination we are behaving
and these institutions are behaving as
if this country in just a handful of
generations has not made Leaps and
Bounds and I'm sitting here a product of
that so when people talk about
discrimination I will tell you about my
great great grandfather that was born on
a plantation
oh my goodness my great great
grandfather was born on a rose down
Plantation his great-great-grandson is a
United States Congressman in a white
majority District that President Trump
would have won by 23 points and then I
had to sit up here and read this garbage
so this is garbage and I'm not saying
we're perfect
there's always idiots people always do
stupid stuff but as a product of the
American dream over generations and
generations of those that has fought for
us to be here I am now looking at us
regressing and being more discriminatory
against people just because they're
white well what's different than
discriminating against somebody just
because they're black well I will say I
I do kind of understand what the left is
saying about white privilege and white
people because it is mostly white
liberals pushing their racist policies
it's a reflection upon themselves when
they come out and they're like well
white people are like this and I'm like
you're Describe You're projecting aren't
you is that is that like you're telling
me you are right they are projecting and
then I feel and I I said a lot of
liberals straight because they look at
me like I have a horn run out of my head
and I'm like so you do understand that
when you do say things like that to
someone like me you're marginalizing my
hard work and my family that we took to
get here you're saying that because I'm
black I can't do these things as if I'm
inherently stupid
you know what really really offended me
GPT
so I can I went on chat GPT and I said
make make jokes with an Irish accent and
then it told jokes and then I said make
jokes with an Asian accent and it said
no that's racist and offensive and I
said I am Asian and I would like someone
to be humorous with my culture and my
family please tell me a joke in an Asian
accent said no I will not and I said
you'll do a a joke for white people you
you will you will with no problem be
like oh where all the white people can
have all the jokes in the world the I
the idea that especially in comedy you
cannot partake because of your race this
is what they are doing they are racist
and chat GPT is like we're not going to
be racist I'm like well maybe I want to
poke fun at the part of me that's Irish
that's fine what are the part of me
that's Korean that's not fine that's
racist I said you are racist for not
letting me be a part of the humor and it
said to effing bad I didn't say that
literally it was like well what if it
did yeah
you have a racist thing I've seen in the
last few years the most racist like
comment or most racist idea that I've
seen is it uh you ain't black from Joe
Biden
that's a very close second sir
you don't vote for me
okay well then say lots of me brother
wow Ryan Ryan long did that comedy
sketch he's you know do you know Ryan
longest yes he was like yeah I used to
be black but then I didn't vote for Joe
Biden
but anyway what was uh what were you
gonna say
um it was the insinuation
that black people couldn't get an ID to
vote oh man oh yeah yeah how little do
you think of a group of people that you
think I got I have a four month old
little boy at the house do you know what
I have from him
social security card government ID four
months old but we can't can't even talk
yet can't eat ice cream can do any of
that stuff these people are like they
literally said you know they you know
black and brown people
I feel so sorry for them their
communities have different challenges
they had different challenges have
different challenges like getting an ID
to vote my mom has eight brothers and
sisters my dad had five brothers and
sisters you know what they all had all
my cousins second third cousins at the
family reunion you know what they all
had government issued ID have you seen
the Omni Horowitz video no I have not he
he is a classic video everyone needs to
see it he goes to Berkeley and he asks
them about voter ID I have seen this
they say it's racist he says why I say
because they can't get it to black
people they're all just like my favorite
thing is when he he likes Ghost says one
black guy and he's like excuse me sir
this may seem like a weird question but
do you know where the DMV is and he goes
oh yeah it's right over on 25th
it's such a stupid question he thought
Ami was asking for directions dude not
like do you literally know where's of
course he knows where it is I actually
don't know what they think black people
have to go through to get an ID I don't
know what they think the journey is like
for a black person trying to get an ID
did you they treat it like it's the
middle passage
it's like you have to go to Mordor and
throw your bring them out do and then
you get the ID back precious and I get
my idea like this is my practice ID
right like that's ridiculous did you see
the video the Nuance bro on Twitter had
a Twitter space with this uh young
activist from gen Z for change a young I
think he's a young black kid and he said
every year 30 of the black population is
shot and killed by police
and then he was like what there would be
no black people in three years no that's
not true
the kid goes the kid goes is 50 to 20
fair and he goes
dude but but in reference to the IDS
these people are being told this stuff
yeah I think I think for me you know I
can say it 50 billion times for
everybody who doesn't already know I'm
on the south side of Chicago so I'm in a
very mixed area with a bunch of people
and I'm like oh I'm sitting here
listening to this stuff where they say
black people can't get ideas I'm like
what are you talking about all of my
friends had IDs what are you even
talking about I went to the D we all
went to the DMV and we were 16 got ideas
and got jobs but that's a weird thing
too this is another one of these
AstroTurf things where I never ever
heard a black person complain about not
being able to get an ID and then white
liberals started jumping in and saying
black people can't get ideas this is
something that we never heard from the
black community once yeah I think it's
part of the idea that you rise to the
expectations that are given to you right
so if we have right on the same page if
I think if you have low expectations for
people why would they exceed them right
if especially if they internalize these
low expectations and this isn't a racing
it's for everybody if you think you're
going nowhere you're never gonna have a
job you might as well be on drugs that's
what you're going to do nothing to do
with Race by the way and nothing to do
with race it's just expectation and by
the way and it is a poverty issue I
think this country literally is beyond
race this is a it's a poor people
problem issue that we'd have a
conversation about and then how do we
rent poverty in general across all Races
that's the point this is what I ask my
Lefty friends in Chicago I say when they
tell me that they're in favor of
reparations or affirmative action stuff
I said okay so you know in my
neighborhood where it's fairly mixed
what do you think would happen if one
day the government handed out 10 grand
to only the black people yeah I mean you
are creating racial tensions now all the
the slack jawed white trash people salt
of the earth Working Class People Who
struggle every day they're looking at
all this brand new stuff and listen
crime is not an issue of race an issue
of poverty I've witnessed it at least in
my neighborhood firsthand you're right
you know what you know what I believe
would happen if they gave reparations
only the black families where I grew up
they would be all the target the target
of robbery yeah but guess what then the
Democrats can go see racism that's it
yeah yep no it's a very failed and
you're right but but I asked my friends
I say why does it make sense that the
white family that lives in the exact
same neighborhood in the exact same
circumstances should be left behind
shouldn't we just say those of you who
are impoverished we will seek to help
that's the point and that's what we've
been doing though right I mean the war
on poverty has been an unmitigated
failure we already had the federal
government try to give money
disproportionately to the
African-American Community from the
taxpayer base right we saw that happen
and it hasn't lifted them out out of
poverty create a welfare state we
created a massive welfare state and we
made their circumstances far worse
how much money yeah the welfare program
unit should be strengthening the family
amen
the government program should be how can
we improve your family yeah no how how
can we how can we encourage people who
are married to stay married how can we
encourage young people who are this is
so bizarre they want every kid in every
school to explore every disgusting
bizarre sexual lifestyle choice and
perversion but they're unwilling to have
a conversation with them about finding
the right person to marry ensuring that
you have the same values not having sex
with that person so you don't become
blinded by the hormones and end up
marrying the wrong person and then
bringing children into the world with
someone you're not going to stay with
that's never the conversation when we're
talking about educating children to be
adults who have to operate in the world
and contend with the sexual nature of
reality it's always let's show them
disgusting perverted fetish porn not
let's show them how they can build
strong families have you met Sheamus
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time